es ist zeit gurken zu pflanzen also
kommt mit schnappt euch eure
gurkenpflanzen ich zeig euch heute wie
das geht was man dabei beachten muss und
die balkone gärtnerinnen unter euch
haben heute auch glück denn wir werden
auch darüber sprechen wie man die gurken
im kübel gepflanzt
starten wir erst mal mit der frage wie
viele pflanzen man denn überhaupt
braucht also wenn ihr das ziel habt gar
keine gurken mehr einzukaufen dann würde
ich sagen dass man so ungefähr zwei bis
vier pflanzen pro person braucht da sind
aber dann auch einlegegurken mit dabei
gerechnet wenn man seine eigenen sauren
gurken machen möchte nur zum snacken da
braucht man nicht mehr als zwei pflanzen
pro person ich bin generell einfach ein
großer freund von mischkultur weil sich
viele pflanzen einfach gegenseitig
unterstützen und die gurken die wachsen
total gerne neben spinat neben salat
bohnen oder zwiebeln das sind tolle
partner auch knoblauch werden superbad
partner für die gurken auch wenn man dem
topf an bord kann man zum beispiel ein
paar knoblauchzehen noch und in den topf
mit rein stecken dann wird die
jugendlich ganz allein sind sondern in
guter gesellschaft gurken sind ja eher
wärme liebende pflanzen
das heißt sie freuen sich auch über
einen boden der sich schnell erwärmt
sandige böden sind oft ein bisschen
schneller als die schwereren böden dafür
darüber freuen sich die gurken die mögen
aber auch total gerne einen ganz humosen
und kompost reichen boden
deswegen wachsen die gurken auch so
unglaublich gut in unseren kompost
bieten generell lieben gurken sondern
man muss aber ein bisschen
differenzieren je nachdem ob man die
gurken im freiland an bord ob man im
gewächshaus hat in dem sie stehen sollen
oder ob man die gurken auf dem balkon
anbaut weil es ihnen mit der sonne auch
schnell mal ein bisschen zu viel werden
kann und ein bisschen zu heiß werden
kann
im gewächshaus ist ja sowieso viel
wärmer und da ist es ganz gut wenn die
gurken ein eher etwas schattiges
plätzchen haben ich pflanze zum beispiel
hier in die hinterste ecke wo ich weiß
dass es ein bisschen schattiger ist als
ganz vorne an der südseite und auf dem
balkon da staut sich auch die hitze ganz
schnell vor der mauer die macher
reflektiert auch das uv licht so dass es
schnell ein bisschen zu viel für unsere
gurken pflänzchen wird so dass ich auf
dem balkon auch er ein etwas schattiges
plätzchen suchen würde wo sie aber
trotzdem noch ihre fünf stunden volle
sonnenbrillen bekommen ich baue meine
guten ganz gerne an rang gerissen an
einfach weil man deinen pro quadratmeter
je mehr pflanzen
anbauen kann wer pflanzen wenn wir an
christa haben so ungefähr zwei bis drei
gurken pro quadratmeter sonst ist dass
er so ein bis zwei gurken die man
anbauen kann wenn man die einfach über
dem boden kriechen lässt außerdem
bleiben die gurken in sauberer und
deswegen stehen wir voll aufwand
geringste ich zeige euch auch gleich
noch eine art von rang ist die man
aufbauen kann das nicht so kompliziert
ist wie das teil jetzt ja gurken sind
ziemlich anfällig für mehltau früher
oder später schlägt der jedes jahr zu da
gibt es einen trick mit dem man trotzdem
noch eine gute gurkenernte haben kann
und zwar ziehen wir ja ab mitte april
ungefähr die gurken im haus vor
aber jetzt mitte mai wenn die guten nach
draußen gepflanzt werden können dann
sehen wir auch gleichzeitig an einem
anderen ort im garten noch mal gurken
direkt in den boden aus so dass wir noch
eine zweite jüngere gurken generation
haben die dann weniger anfällig sind
wenn die alten pflanzen schon vom
mehltau betroffen sind dann geben die
jüngeren immer noch eine ganz gute ernte
ab und so kann man das ein bisschen
abpuffern also jetzt nicht nur guten
pflanzen sondern eigentlich auch gesehen
ist mir ganz clevere idee ich gebe ihnen
einen langzeitdünger mit ins pflanzloch
das sind jetzt hornspäne die wir
verwenden ein biologischer dünger der
ganz lange wirkt und jetzt einfach mal
ein pflanzloch das ungefähr so groß ist
wie der topf in dem die gurke ist und
wir wollen die ungefähr so tief
einpflanzen wie sie auch im topf steht
also die muss nicht tiefer gesetzt
werden die muss nicht oben rausschauen
das ist gerade wenn man veredelte gurken
pflanzt auch super wichtig dass man
darauf achtet dass die veredelungsstelle
nie unter der erde ist weil sonst hat
das ganze veredeln einfach gar nichts
gebracht
und da gebe ich jetzt ungefähr zwei
esslöffel hornspäne mit ins pflanzloch
und die arbeite ich auch immer noch ein
bisschen ein mit der schaufel so dass
sie sich mit dem boden ein bisschen
vermischen und dann kommt unser
plätzchen drauf so und mit erde wieder
bedeckt leicht angedrückt und was ich
jetzt ganz gerne mache ist ein gis
rantum das pflänzchen drumrum anzulegen
dafür ziehe ich einfach so eine kleine
rolle hier um das pflänzchen drum rum
weil wir das ja in den nächsten wochen
immer noch schön gießen damit es gut
anwachsen
kann und so stimmt das wasser einfach
nicht weg sondern bleibt da wo es hin
soll
und das ist super praktisch nicht nur
bei gurken sondern bei allen anderen
gemüsen auch und dann gut an gießen so
dass die wurzeln ein geschlemmt werden
und die pflanze richtig schön anwachsen
kann
man brauche jetzt kein fans ihr an
christ und burgen anzubauen es reicht
auch wenn man einfach einen stab in die
erde steckt der sollte natürlich
möglichst lange sein damit die gurken
auch möglichst hoch wachsen können
es ist ganz wichtig egal was für ein
christ ihr habt dass ihr die gurken
immer wieder zwischendurch fest bindet
weil der wind sie sonst einfach wegsehen
kann so dass sie einfach gut fixiert
sind ihr könnt auch einfach drei stäbe
nehmen und die so in die erde stecken
wie ein tipi einfach mal oben
zusammenbinden so hat man sich auch ein
superschönes ein gerüst aufgebaut es
geht ganz schnell da muss man sich nicht
die mühe geben und da ist irgendwie was
tolles flächen aber wenn ihr darauf lust
habt dann macht es auf jeden fall des
eingriffs video kommt auf jeden fall
noch ich weiß ich verspreche euch das
andauernd das dauert noch ein bisschen
ich pflanze ist aber noch eine gurke
hier ins hochbeet so dass sie dann
später hier schön runter wachsen kann
dann hängt die einfach über die kante
rüber und kann sich die gurken da
absammeln da braucht man dann kein
rankgerüst dass wir auch ein bisschen zu
viel wenn man hier noch ranke riss
darauf bauen würde dann wäre das mit dem
wind nicht so ganz praktisch und man
wird auch überhaupt nicht mehr dran
kommen
aber das klappt eben auch dass man die
gurken einfach aus dem hochbeet runter
hängen lässt dann mach ich jetzt auch
wieder mein loch da kommen wieder die
hornspäne rein diesmal ein bisschen
weniger weil das hochbeet ein bisschen
besser gedämmt ist als die normalen
beete und dann kommt da unser pflänzchen
rein
[Musik]
kommen wir dazu wie man gurken ins
gewächshaus pflanzt dazu finden wir
immer schnüre oben an drähten fest die
durchs gewächshaus gespannt sind und das
sind die einfach runter hängen so dass
sie so ein bisschen spiel haben über dem
erdboden
und dann können wir da unsere guten plan
hoch leiten sie haben ja auch ein loch
zum pflanzen und die bekommen auch genau
die gleiche düngung wie die pflanzen im
freiland also seit zwei esslöffel
hornspäne die wir gut einarbeiten
meine guten pflanzlichen sind schon
richtig groß weil wir die im februar
schon aussehen mussten damit dieses
video hier für euch fertig werden konnte
mein garten leidet regelmäßig darunter
dass sich youtube videos über das
gärtnern 8 die freuen sich auf jeden
fall her unglaublich dass sie jetzt in
die erde können glaube ich wir sind
nicht die einzigen die gurken total
lecker finden schnecken stehen auch voll
auf die deswegen steht sich die gurken
jungen pflänzchen immer mit schnecken
kragen
die sind so gebaut dass sie schnecken
hier nicht rüberkommen weil sie da nicht
kopfüber kriechen können und die stecke
ich auf die pflänzchen warum steckt wie
so ein bisschen in die erde so dass die
pflanzen zumindest für die nächsten zwei
drei wochen noch ganz gut vor schnecken
geschützt sind später sind sie dann groß
genug dann sind sie nicht mehr so zart
und lecker und dann kommen die schnecken
auch nicht mehr und machen nicht mehr so
viel schaden aber jetzt ist es total
schade wenn man alle gurken pflänzchen
in einer nacht an die schnecken
verlieren würde
ihr habt das bestimmt schon mal gehört
gurken können im sommer bitter werden
und wenn man die dann ist dann sind die
ziemlich giftig schmeckt auch überhaupt
nicht dass es gar keine lustige sache da
muss man also gut aufpassen
und das passiert wenn sie nicht
gleichmäßig mit wasser versorgt sind und
es passiert auch richtig schnell wenn
die gurken bei trockenheit stress haben
deswegen ist es erstens total wichtig
dass man guten schön dicht und zweitens
auch wichtig dass man die regelmäßig
gießt ihr kennt ja wahrscheinlich meinen
kanal und willst da sie versuchen
möglichst gar nicht zu gießen im
freiland im gewächshaus kommt man nicht
drumrum da kann es ja nicht reinregnet
und in den hochbeeten funktioniert das
auch nicht so super aber in den
ebenerdigen beten wiesen wir nach dem
die pflanzen einmal angewachsen sind so
gut wie gar nicht mehr
und das kann man bei gurken einfach
knicken das ist das einzige gemüse das
bei uns regelmäßig das ganze jahr über
den ganzen sommer über bis in den herbst
hinein immer mit der gießkanne versorgt
wird damit die gurken nicht bitter
werden und wissen die auch mehrmals in
der woche nicht nur einmal in der woche
sondern alle paar tage damit der boden
immer gleichmäßig feucht bleibt weil es
einfach super ärgerlich ist wenn die
ganzen burgen bitter werden und wenn die
alle in die tonne kloppen kann ich tue
jetzt mal so es wäre das nicht der
topinambur job den wir vor ein paar
wochen gepflanzt haben sondern es werden
wir jetzt brücken im topf pflanzen
wollen ja es ist erst mal total wichtig
dass der topf möglichst groß ist wir
reden davon ungefähr 20 litern besser
mehr in so einem maurer kübel könnte man
zwei gurkenpflanzen nebeneinander
anbauen das ist also ganz praktisch man
kann natürlich auch gurken in den 15
liter topf oder einem kleineren topf
anbauen
aber der tag wird er nie so berauschend
sein also 20 liter würde ich sagen ist
das minimum damit das auch richtig gut
funktioniert ganz wichtig wenn man
gemüse im topf an bord ist natürlich
dass der topf und löcher hat so dass
sich das wasser nicht staut es ist auch
ganz klug wenn man eine drainageschicht
aus kies ins untere drittel rein gibt
und dann fühlen wir das einfach mit
einer schönen pflanzerde ich verwende am
liebsten torffreie erde aus ökologischen
gründen und dann denken wir die trotzdem
noch auf weil die gurken ebenen stark
zähler sind das heißt wir bringen jetzt
in der pflanzerde trotzdem noch
hornspäne aus ich mache das jetzt nicht
und tobago nicht zu verwirren und da
werde ich jetzt auch mal statt den zwei
esslöffeln die wir draußen verwendet
haben also ungefähr drei oder vier es
dafür verwenden weil die gurken jahr ein
viel kleineres volumen haben indem es
über purzeln können da müssen wir
trotzdem noch alle nährstoffe drin
vorkommen dann würdet ihr einfach ganz
normal ein loch und die gurke wandert in
den topf auch wieder so dass das obere
topf niveau auf höhe der erde im topf
ist so dass ich nicht zu tief und nicht
zu hoch eingepflanzt wird wir machen
auch wieder einen gips tragen und gießen
sie schön an und auch die gurken im topf
brauchen eine rankhilfe dafür kann man
entweder einen stock reinstecken oder so
eine spirale starb wie man die von
tomaten kennt oder auch nicht nur die
man oben an der terrassen decke fest
bindet
aber jetzt sind ja nicht nur die gurken
fällig die tomaten dürfen jetzt auch
nach draußen gepflanzt werden und damit
ihr wisst was ihr dabei beachten ist
schaut gerne da trieben vorbei da habe
ich nämlich auch schon mal ein ganzes
video drüber gemacht mit der spezielle
mixtur die ich ins pflanzloch gebe und
so weiter also schaut auf jeden fall
vorbei ansonsten sehen wir uns am
nächsten samstag wieder um 10 uhr für
ein neues video
[Musik]